Цей електрокар Sion пройшов довгий шлях
від прототипу, який збудували кілька
студентів у гаражі в Мюнхені
У 2016 році юнаки почали збір коштів
через краудфандингові платформи
на втілення проекту
Їм вдалось зібрати близько мільйона євро
Стартап Sono Motors презентував фінальну версію електрокару Sion
в липні 2017 року
Ззовні ми оснастили автівку сонячними панелями
це означає, що ми в звичайний сонячний день у Мюнхені
можемо акумулювати енергію
на додаткові 30 кілометрів.
А отже, ми можемо істотно зменшити
кількість підзарядок
Тож водіям більше не доведеться хвилюватись
що в них закінчиться електроенергія до того
як вони доїдуть до наступної станції підзарядки
Практичний дизайн від команди Sono Motors
Sion має бути практичною автівкою на кожен день
вона має великий багажник - 650 літрів
туди усе вміщається - коляска, покупки
Я можу причепити до цієї автівки причіп
Тобто, в мене цілком повноцінний засіб пересування, простий, без прибамбасів
Та чи доступний Sion звичайному споживачеві?
Перші моделі на ринку коштуватимуть
16 тисяч євро
плюс 4 тисячі за батарею
В компанії кажуть, близько семи тисяч електрокарів уже замовлені
їх виготовлять до кінця наступного року